Zakia I feel that the next question of
all the questions that we've got to ask
today will perhap shock quite a few
people um the issue of a man and his
wife um perhaps sitting on a sofa or
some other place of comfort and the
husband delivers a kiss on the wife's
face let's say for or the lips of the
wife is this an action which nullifies
the fast or is permitted while fasting
if a husband kisses the wife or hugs the
wife or shows his love for the wife by
kissing on the cheek or the lip or the
hand or hugs or Embraces all these
things are permissible as long as it
does not encourage him to go into an act
which is Haram for
fasting and this is very well stated in
theth ofi wasallam it's mentioned in say
bukari number three in the book of
fasting Hadith number
1927 that a be pleased with her she says
that the prophet used to kiss and
embrace his wives while
fasting but he was the best amongst you
to control himself that means the
prophet had the power to control
similarly it's mentioned in Sun Abu da
volume number two Hadith number 2379
that Omar be pleased with him once while
he
fasting kisses his
wife immediately he feels sorry and he
goes to the prophet and he says that oh
Prophet I have sinned I've sinned
against you and Allah so the prophet
says that what have you done he says
that while fasting I've kissed my wife
so the prophet asked him that when you
goggle or rinse your mouth while doing
woodoo does your fast break so him he
said
no so why bother indicating to him that
you can kiss and embrace your wife
furthermore there's a Hadith which is
mentioned in mus Ahmed volume number two
Hadith number
6739 one of the sahabah he narrates that
a young man comes to prophet malli
wasallam and asks him that can I kiss my
wife why I'm fasting the prophet says no
later
on an old man comes to the prophet and
asks him that can I kiss my wife while
fasting and the prophet says yes so the
sahaba look amongst themselves that how
come that say differing then the prophet
replies that this man can control
himself so the basic ruling is that if a
person knows that he can control himself
after kissing or hugging his wife and he
sure that it will not lead into an act
which will nullify the fast for example
it will not lead into a sexual
intercourse or will not lead into
ejaculation as long as he can control
himself kissing and hugging is permitted
if he cannot control himself and he
fears that he will go into the ACT which
will nullify the fast like intercourse
or ejaculation then it is prohibit for
him the answer is yes but it comes with
a an Islamic health warning that's right
okay